hello everybody hope that you're good
first of all thank you very much for all
your support we've had a great start of
the year in terms of trading and I
cannot answer all your messages but I
read them all so thank you so much for
all the love you sent me guys it keeps
me motivated and um makes me want to sh
more setup so um yeah we're going to
talk about this range first then we'll
go into the week into the daily time
frame to talk about those weeks that we
got in Bitcoin also want to talk about
the ethereum and Bitcoin pair the
Bitcoin dominance and some Al coins like
the Trump mcoin so it's going to be um a
video pack of information I'm going to
to keep it nice and short so make sure
to pay attention to it okay now in terms
of trading I think this range
environment is one of the best um uh
scenarios that we could get I've been
publicly trading and favoring Longs
since the range lows and I've been
posting all the setups and all my
thoughts and trades on X and my telegram
channel that it's free by the way so you
can join in the description and I'll
tell you the way I've been trading this
so uh very quickly the first thing that
I noticed was this long week here never
got filed the 100% and there was a lot
of liquidity right below it so that was
two Sunday updates ago I posted I was
very likely to see something like this
then well took the loan from 90k closed
that the mid-range at 990k so that was a
very nice tra then once you got the
mid-range you can see by the way how
each level I have the range highs the
range lows the mid-range top range
quarter and bottom range quarter and you
can see how every time that are retest
for example here you get deviation you
get a retest
continuation here the same retest
continuation at the midrange the same
retest and the deviation that I've
called in advance before it happened
that's when I took my uh long position
at the 1 out 8 that it was around here
took that long to the top range quarter
at the top range quarter you can see the
same a retest there and then
continuation to almost the range highs
and then on Sunday two days ago I
mentioned the idea that it was very
likely to see something like this a drop
to the 4 or 15 that you can see how it
was overextended would didn't tast it
for quite a long time almost whole week
we got that retest open the
long okay and continuation to the range
highs here we talked about the
possibility of a deviation all right and
we went back down to the top range qu to
the 4H hour 50 m that right now it's
holding a support so basically all I've
been doing is long every single retest
that I could H get now something changed
and it was this deviation here you can
see the deviation there at the top of
the range which uh I take with a lot of
caution because usually what happens is
and I'm not saying this is going to
happen I'm saying that usually what
happens is that you get some kind of
retest of resistance and then you can
drop to the mid-range or even lower to
the range low so um I'm not saying that
the market has stopped out or anything
like that I'm just um Talking In terms
of day trading and of course only
talking about this range and I would
like to see a breakout but right now I
remain cous here okay so the way that
I'm trading this and I've posted it
yesterday that's around uh 24 hours ago
on X the Tuesday update I posted that I
took a long from um the top range
quarter that's
102,000 point4 okay and we came to the 4
R 15ma added some to my position average
entry around 102k exactly okay now from
here what I'm expecting is to go back to
the range SI simply because if we go
into the daily time frame okay and let
me remove the range for a
second there you go and also let me get
rid of the 50 Ma and activate the quick
F strategy you can see here guys that we
go
a few weeks okay let it load to be fast
there it is we got first of all this
week to the upside that we created
yesterday that I'm expecting it to get
filled that's what I talked yesterday we
almost got there I think we filed around
40% so perhaps that's done okay um I
also contemplate the idea that perhaps
that's the 50% fa a tiny bit lower but
that might be done okay then you also
have this week here that's around the
mid-range and of course this daily week
are the range low so you got a problem
here well you got three problems you got
the problem of the three weeks now it's
possible that all of them get filled in
fact around 96% of all the weeks get
filled sooner or later the problem is
that we don't know how long it'll take
and I did cool and you guys have noticed
I didn't talk about this weeks before
because I could see momentum to the
upside so to me even though I saw these
weeks in the daily time frame there was
no point in trading towards them because
the momentum was pointing towards higher
prices continue pushing price higher you
know catching the retail Trader uh of
guard and hitting their short
liquidations okay because at range lows
and during this move up the market was
quite buries I mean the market sentiment
really not not the market itself because
you know really what Market is doing
just trading a range nothing else but in
terms of Market sentiment it was quite
very so you mean that usually pushes
momentum higher to hit all those long
liquidations and stop losses so yeah we
got three weeks there we're going to
talk about how why it's possible that we
fill all of them okay so let me go back
here okay to how in my range there so
what I'm talking about here is that it's
likely that we could well perhaps again
perhaps that week to the upsite is is
done um i' I've also mentioned in telam
a few hours ago I took um 50% profits at
104k from my long position partial
profits cuz it's halfway I'll take the
rest of the 50% at the range highs if we
get there so my idea is see if price can
go to the range highs fill this week
completely well
at least 50% of it so we can fully
discard this week and if we see a
rejection from this resistance then and
take a short towards the midrange what
we have this week here okay the 50% if
you notice it's around the mid range so
at here at the mid-range is what I would
take at least 2/3 of profits of my
position all right so um let's see what
happens also at the level you're going
to have
the daily 50ma that should act as
support So something like this can
happen and if we see a breakdown from
here and we lose the daily 50ma and the
mid-range then of course the next level
is the range lows again we're going to
trade level by level I'm not forecasting
this to happen okay and I don't care if
it happens or not all I care is what are
the reactions that we're going to see at
each level in in the chart for example
If instead we see something like this a
breakout consolidation above the range
highs okay that is telling me it's
possible that the that this resistance
is now support so we could continue
going higher and instead of trying to
look for shorts at the range highs I
look for another long okay to push it to
potentially 114
115k so yeah pretty much I'm not Mar
into any idea I'm just making out some
some some plans for my trading and at
the moment I'm in a position with 50% of
size potentially I want to see the range
highs getting retested and a reaction
from there a rejection really where I
would take a short to the mid-range
important I'm not setting limit orders
short limit orders at the range highs
I'm not doing that because they might
get front run okay and price could
continue going higher so what I'm
looking here is observing the reaction
okay if he rejects I'll trade the move
down to the
mid-range here take out most of my
position and if we lose this level
midrange and daily 50a then continue
trading towards the range lows
potentially compounding or add inside
here to my position right that's all
that I'm trading and not much more now
if if we move into the Bitcoin dominance
cuz you guys have been asking me about
it quite a lot and this chart is another
chart that I've been uh guessing
correctly what it's doing lately but and
I'm scared that that might change soon
so let's see if I'm right or not and
here what I'm looking for is to
continuously
seeing a lower highs
right and for that what I want to see
let me get this right for you guys in
fact if you go to the 12 hours time
frame might be easier yeah that's
easier I want to continuously
see lower highs for example this is a
lower high this right now would be
another lower high okay you going do
something like this continue dropping
well in fact you should see a drop lower
than this ideally okay and then another
lower high and then continue dropping
that's kind of like the trend that I
would like to see and so far to be
honest nothing really has happened since
the last update and all of this move
here is quite pointless nothing's
happened and I'll change my mind if I
see this High here I let me get a
straight line cuz I cannot do with the
touchpad of my laptop
and if we see a breakout Above This
level there above this jellow
line then that worry me because my idea
of seeing lower highs um would be
invalidated and then we could
potentially revisit again those highs or
even going higher so yeah pretty much
what I want to see is a lower high and
we could even go all the way here but
then I need to see a drop
right so uh that's what I have in mind
for the Bitcoin
dominance nothing more than that nothing
is really happening now in the Bitcoin
sorry in ethereum and Bitcoin pair I
don't know guys if you remember this
chart here where everybody on city was
calling this as a low and I've been
keeping four months now this Z line as
the potential support level or bottom
level you can see how we perfectly tack
the area now let's see let's see if this
is the correct uh bottom or not but this
chart is uh you can see that you know if
ethereum is losing power versus Bitcoin
that means that ethereum is not is not
going to do really well you know Bitcoin
is going to outperform ethereum and
that's what has been happening that's
why you see ethereum really not moving
so if this becomes the bottom and we
start to see a reaction from here and
this chart is starting to go up they're
want to see ethereum out performing
Bitcoin and if Bitcoin that means that
Bitcoin goes up ethereum goes higher
okay in terms of percentages so um
that's what I would like to see in this
chart is see how this yellow line reacts
um if this becomes support and we can
see a reaction from there that would be
great and
yeah um in terms of
altcoins you know usually the cycle is
Bitcoin goes up then ethereum goes up so
far you haven't seen that cuz ethereum
is not outperforming Bitcoin but if this
is the bottom then you're going to see
that phe of the of the bull market that
it's ethereum um you know going forwards
against Bitcoin and then once that
happens then that's when alins can start
to go up so uh I think I think Al coins
is still might need a bit longer
especially because we have you know all
these meme coins of of of trump of uh
Melania that and they're taking a lot of
the liquidity from the market um well
from the Alid markets really so um it's
not great for other alquin except for
example Solana because it is in the Sol
blockchain so this coin is taking a lot
of the liquidity and in terms of
investing in it I think it's an awful
idea because the economics are are
really bad I've talked about it but uh
investing starts in 3 months which is
super fast usually it's around 12 months
and also 80% of all the tokens are hold
by a few wallets so they can manipulate
price very easily all I see with this
coin is that yes it's taking a lot of
liquidity it's very volatile because
many people are trading it so we can
take it we can use it for just day
trading right not for investing in it
cuz I had um one of my best friends he's
on to crypto and he said wow you know
Trump has loed a meme coin he's now in
the white house should I buy Trump for
the long term and I think it would be a
bold move and I've told him you know you
can do what you want but I wouldn't only
use it for trading if if you are willing
into B not for investing really and some
setups that I've seen and that I've been
trading is this you can see this was a
resistance that became support then I
was you know trading this deviation here
so that's so far what I what I've been
trading last night I took two entries
one around here one at the retest you
know that was a take profit that was a
take profit now what I'm waiting for is
to see if we see another retest that's
another entry that here will be another
take profits retest here of this
resistance into support that will be
another
entry that candle here that will be
another take profits so these are the
type of trading setups that you can take
with this coin just you know quick ins
and out that's what I would uh recommend
so you don't get CAU of guard and for
Solana
Solana um very happy with Solana it's
been you know performing pretty well I
would say in the last few days and so
far here again what I would like to see
is hang on what is my 50a that it is is
to see the 4our 50a holding you also
have here a few weeks to the downside
price progressing any further so let's
continue be that way and if we start to
see a few more in this area here that
means that you know price will reverse
and continue you know taking for example
look at this week I see a week right
there you know all those levels there so
um I wouldn't trade other alquin really
um because I think that they might take
a bit longer to start to outperform the
rest of the market so for right now I'm
sticking to bitcoin and let's see if the
ethereum Bitcoin pair this is a reaction
then I'll continue trading well I start
trading ethereum but for alom really
just Trump because he has a lot of
volatility Solana for the same reason
and if you want to continue with the
with the mcoin you know narrative for
example started to trade also this coin
here then um only in a spot because you
can see how let me go to the Daily time
frame it's quite volatile
you know is listed in binance in spot
and in Futures it's a well the only cat
M coin that is listed in spot and
Futures in binance so yeah it's taking a
lot of liquidity from the market a lot
of volatility and only I'm only trading
this in terms of um in in spot trading
really so for example go to the 4our
time frame one setup I was looking at
here but I failed was you know you go
here
support then you get the deviation you
get a retest so I enter that retest
didn't take profits here cuz I was
expecting prices to go higher to retrace
all these imbalances all these liquidity
pools it didn't round trip my position
retest of this support of resistance got
out a break even price continues
dropping so right now I'm not in into
this but if we see let me remove this
yellow
line let me let me remove this yellow
line but if we see something like this
another drop into this support and we
see a reaction then that's what I'm
taking an entry back into these levels
here okay again in a spot because this
move for example here that's already a
50% move up I don't need Leverage for
this don't need to okay so yep
not great for altcoins in terms of
trading just focusing on bitcoin for now
and let's see if in the near future we
can also trade ethereum okay uh by the
way ethereum in the last video um if you
guys remember we we talked about this
level here this deviation in fact that
that drawing there is from the last
video I didn't move it so you know you
got support deviation was likely to
happen also you go there the weekly 50ma
so if we change the 50ma to the weekly
time frame though I want to see changing
there one two 3 go there you can see
also there retest of the weekly 15a and
AD devation so as long as we continue
holding this level and holding into the
this long position but it's really a
sport position okay and yeah and if
that's the case then you know we're
going to attack again those Highs at
4,000 so right now all I can say for
ethereum is let's see if the weekly 50ma
holds any retrace back into that level
is for buying in a spot and selling into
those range highs all right which that
would be a very
nice uh 33% move something like that yes
33% move and of course if ethereum and
Bitcoin
pair marks the bottom from that yellow
line okay so if we see something like
this WS to the downside but price is not
breaking down going low okay then that's
usually a signal of a reversal and price
you know well price really not but
ethereum kind to start to take a bit
more control control against Bitcoin so
that's pretty much everything that I'm
looking guys so thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon